a deadly heat wave is gripping Europe
it's starting to break today that's good
news
at least 10 European countries have
experienced record temperatures this
summer Europe is now on track for the
hottest July ever recorded one woman
died yesterday in Belgium in more than
104 degree heat Ian Lee is in Paris
where temperatures have set a new
all-time high so Ian what's the
temperature there today Dale it's a nice
81 degrees right now but yesterday much
of Europe felt like an oven and because
the AC isn't widespread across the
continents that means that they needed a
degree of creativity to keep cool
temperatures soared as records tumbled
across Europe in the UK the mercury hit
100 while Germany reached 106 and here
in France Paris smashed its all-time
high with 108 jet spray relief for
tourists wanting to beat the heat
outside the Eiffel Tower but there's a
serious side to the frolicking and the
fountains warned meteorologists in 2003
a heat wave killed more than 20,000
people across Europe
this one delayed trains in several
countries melted glaciers then flooded a
Swiss resort forced nuclear plants in
France and Germany to take reactors
offline and even had officials spearing
the notre-dame Cathedral which almost
burned down in April could see its
damaged ceiling collapse from this
latest Inferno this is the second heat
wave in as many months making it the
hottest summer on record with
temperatures more like Baghdad in Cairo
than your typical European city the
continent now faces another
middle-eastern problem scientists call
it the urban heat island buildings and
roads absorbing the heat during the day
then releasing it at night like a
radiator a new challenge for all Hero
how will that affect cities going
forward like Paris
more urbanized and more concrete you
have over a large area more this urban
heat island effects makes temperatures
rise the ease the heat
experts say cities need to be redesigned
with nature in mind things like more
trees and less concrete Tony scientists
also say it all boils down to climate
change as the reason for these
record-breaking heat waves
if greenhouse gas emissions aren't
reduced they predict extreme heat could
become more frequent and intense and in
fact Ian Lee for us in Paris thank you
very much in and in fact the the in
extreme heat has already become more
frequent and intense we are breaking
more heat records and cold records every
single year and the planet is getting
hotter that's what the experts tell us I
keep thinking about the people who plan
their vacation you're going to Europe
some people for the first time and oh
it's 108 degrees although you're playing
in the fountain by the iPhone that's not
so